et
bonjour et bienvenue le modèle agricole
français est il à bout de souffle le
secteur traverse aujourd'hui une crise
sans précédent en 20 ans le nombre
d'exploitation a été divisé par deux sur
production baisse des prix normes
environnementales les éleveurs sont les
premiers touchés
une souffrance profonde et des revenus
en chute libre
éleveur un métier d'avenir itinéraire
bis vous emmène à la rencontre du monde
agricole
aveyron dans cette édition nous irons à
la rencontre de guillaume producteurs de
lait à tout juste 29 ans il songe déjà à
abandonner son métier
la famille grimal elle a fait le choix
de la production de masse 120000 agneaux
par an et une entreprise qui prospère
enfin serge et isabelle en développer un
tout autre modèle le circuit court
ils ont décidé d'élever de transformer
et de vendre leur production
bonjour guillaume bonjour ça va oui il
est 10 heures vous êtes déjà élevé
depuis bien longtemps voulez vous
travailler
merci de nous recevoir sur votre
exploitation d'autant plus que cheikh
les journées sont très denses et en ce
moment oui il ya beaucoup de boulot
arnal et des mises bas pour pour nous et
c'est également la période de récolte du
maïs non ça fait des journées qui semble
assez costaud qui sont très longues
alors vous êtes un jeune éleveur de
vaches laitières vous êtes installé il y
a cinq ans sur l'exploitation familiale
et vous allez déjà quelques regrets oui
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est très dur
a subi une grosse période assez
difficile je crois une des plus grandes
crises colonie connue et c'est vrai que
se posent beaucoup de questions sur le
futur de nos exploitations aujourd'hui
pour comprendre votre quotidien
guillaume on vous a suivi toute une
journée et 24 heures dans la vie d'un
jeune éleveur ça ressemble à ça
tous les deux jours le même rituel
mais ces derniers mois la collecte du
lait un goût un peu amer celui qui vient
de partir il va servir à payer une
partie des charges pas la totalité
nous on prendra rien dessus parce que il
n'est pas assez payés aujourd'hui ce
serait presque pareil de le vendre ou de
le jeter
c'est un peu la même chose ça ferait
très mal au coeur de se dire qu'on nous
dit on oublie les gens et que qu'on a du
mal
les mêmes gestes répétés matin et soir
plus de 75 heures de travail
hebdomadaires et tout cela à perte avec
50 vaches et litres de lait par jour
lilian mais son père ne s'en sortent
plus au prix du marché
il récupère 300 euros quand il leur en
faudrait au moins 340
je fasse appel à moi je vois que je
travaille pour pour rien quoi et fameux
tout le monde est un peu comme beaucoup
le producteur laitier sont dégoûtés du
métier quoi
la réalité est sans appel avec des coûts
de production plus élevés que le prix du
lait les comptes de l'entreprise
familiale sont dans le rouge
c'est la question c'est quand est-ce que
je vais pouvoir le payer
comment je vais arriver à le payer
qu'est ce que je vais prendre des agios
pour retard de paiement
est ce que est ce qu'on aura assez de
trésorerie pour pour nous que ce prélat
versements si et chaque mois le même
dilemme choisir entre gagner sa vie ou
payer ses factures ne ferment une
exploitation même n'importe quelle
entreprise ne peut pas vendre à perte à
très long terme
c'est impossible vous aimez soit vous
mettez en faillite soit les u6 vianney
avec les dettes qui s'accumulent
beaucoup dans ce département très rural
ont mis la clé sous la porte à tout
juste 29 ans à l'âge où certains ont des
projets guillaume a lui déjà des regrets
je regrette a des fois je regrette un
vrai jeu des fois je me dis est ce que
il vaudrait mieux pas le mieux
avoir deux trois vaches juste pour le
plaisir et travailler ailleurs vu les
conjonctures actuelles plutôt que
d'essayer de vivre à tout prix des
câbles à ce jour là la naissance d'une
petite ville va redonner le sourire ou
de zaoui jacovella je sais c'est le
moment important péché c'est là que la
marche pendant son arrestation
d'abord et quatre enseignants unsa va
jusqu'à menacer les malins on a une
petite femelle
du foin qui récolté sur les sur
l'exploitation
tout ce qu'on leur donne viennent de
produits sur l'exploitation
c'est la première problématique d'une
exploitation c'est d'arriver à
l'autosuffisance du sata force et la
préparent l'aligot ses enfants c'est sa
bouffée d'oxygène
je veux le faire jusqu'au plafond je
vais pas essayer taille c'est chaud il
leur consacre au moins une demi journée
par semaine
regardez sa femme caroline travail elle
chaque jour dans une crèche un choix
mais surtout une nécessité est très
importante du coût puisque puisque bon
enfin là on peut on ne peut pas vivre
seulement avec un salaire enfin son
salaire enfin la culture autrefois là
autrefois une structure comme la nôtre
ça faisait vivre une famille une famille
aisée mais sans que cinq personnes
cherche et du revenu à l'extérieur
aujourd'hui avec les avec les prix bas
qu'on subit tellement ce serait très
compliqué ce serait très compliqué
vient vraiment papilles dans ce petit
village les éleveurs laitiers
abandonnent leur métier les uns après
les autres
à ce rythme là difficile d'imaginer que
l'aveyron reste l'un des départements
français les plus agricoles
philippe guillaume on vous a vu dans ce
reportage des heures de travail à n'en
plus finir des comptes dans le rouge
cette crise vous l'avez vu venir nous à
l'an dernier
sa montée sur une très bonne année
personne ne nous a dit attention ça va
se casser la figure à et c'est vraiment
depuis le mois de décembre et janvier
qu'on subit de plein fouet les
politiques libérales comme n'aime pas ça
l'europe à vous filer vous travaillez
depuis plus de 30 ans sur cette
exploitation des crises comme celle là
vous en avez connu d'autres il y en a eu
mais au début que je veux tu est stable
et déjà il n'y avait pas de prime à la
production laitière n'étaient pas aidés
et on vivait bien du lait ça a commencé
à la casse la gueule à partir du moment
où il y allait de laitières et depuis
maintenant on ne peut pas dire ah on ne
peut pas dire le prix du lait il y aura
400 pendant trois heures quand je me
fais ça les mois comme ça les délais
prévisionnels pour cinq ans mais ne
trompait pas beaucoup il y a cinq mois
fin des quotas laitiers la production de
lait en france a explosé dans le même
temps la demande s'est effondrée
résultat les prix ont baissé certains
éleveurs quand on leur pose la question
disent qu'ils sont les esclaves de la
société moderne le mot est fort c'est
votre sentiment également aujourd'hui
c'est un petit peu le sentiment que
colonna l'europe et de l'agro-industrie
au fond de nous de la main d'oeuvre pas
chère des travailleurs pauvres qui
produisent homme qui essayait du moyen
de produire délais de qualité que
nos industriels qu'on vende sur des
marchés internationaux pour des produits
standards très bas de gamme
manuel valls a promis 3 milliards
d'euros sur trois ans pour la filière
agricole
ça suffit ça va permettre d'enrayer la
crise un report de charge à sa fériés
froid les chalets repousser le problème
un report de charges ça ne rajoute pas
ça ça libère l'urgence aujourd'hui ça
peut me donner un coup de souffle mais
ça règle en rien le problème le problème
est structurel
on redemande et des règles de marché
pour avoir des prix qui sont en cours
est stable à cet été à l'initiative du
ministère de l'agriculture tous les
acteurs de la filière lait se sont mis
autour de la table
ils ont pris des engagements avec un
prix fixe 34 centimes d'euros le litre
de lait cet engagement il a été tenu
non pourquoi après lequel ils peuvent
pas ils peuvent pas ou ne veulent pas le
pas je sais pas
il ya un manque de transparence le prix
est sinon nous le prix inouï de l'est de
moins en moins mais j'ai pas
l'impression que la consommation on
arrive à nous faire ça ailleurs le privé
c'est donc que je sais pas où passe
l'argent
quelques-uns régis bien sur notre dos
sans doute mais qui c'est quoi la
solution selon vous pour mieux vivre de
votre métier aujourd'hui en urgence moi
c'est ce que j'attendais un petit peu de
l'europe à ccc d'une obligation de
baisse de production seront au niveau
européen pour écouler tout le surprise
de l'équipe
qui assure le marché aujourd'hui il y en
a qu'on fait des choix déjà autour de
vous sur la commune on n'est plus 4 je
crois de son talent ne comptez pas sur
les sauver de même il faudra il faut
quand même lui faudra toujours des gens
pour nourrir les dons de la population
mais c'est sûr mais est ce que est ce
que ça se fera dans notre pays il ya
plus de paysans d'aujourd'hui sur sur le
territoire français tous les villages
meurt tous les villages demeurent
aujourd'hui justement face à la crise
certains s'en sortent mieux que d'autres
pour affronter la concurrence ils ont
décidé d'industrialiser les modes
d'élevage un modèle très critiquée
direction le petit village de reuil ac
st cyr là bas la famille grimal a
développé un site agricole hors norme 16
bergerie 120000 agneaux par an une
petite entreprise qui ne connaît pas la
crise mais qui se veut exemplaire pour
apercevoir en entier l'entreprise des
grilles mal il faut grimper au sur les
collines aveyronnaise les seize bergeret
qui s'alignent voit défiler chaque année
cent mille agneaux
c'est la plus grosse exploitation privée
de france un modèle critiqué une ferme
usine diront certains mais pas question
d'utiliser ce terme pour yoann grimal
ici on ne bâcle pas le travail on aura
ce mot me voilà aujourd'hui on est sur
une année
une alimentation qui est tout
automatiser l'aliment est stocké dans
des silos à l'extérieur arrive en
granulés et donc est distribuée via des
vidéos distribution dans chaque dans
chaque loge dans les nourrisseurs on est
bien loin du système traditionnel où les
bêtes sont nourries à la main grâce à
cette automatisation a finalement très
efficace aujourd'hui un de mes salariés
peut lui rendre deux heures le matin
s'occuper de 10000 agneaux et ont passé
l'après midi à faire autant yoann grimal
est un poids lourd de la filière il fait
de l'engraissage d'agneau aucune bête ne
naît ici
yoann les achète à plus de 200
fournisseurs des petits éleveurs avec
qui il travaille sereinement
loin de toute polémique
son exploitation a beau être
industrialisés c'est encore lui qui se
déplacent pour choisir les bêtes et les
contrôles et une par une avant d'acheter
un lot il faut marquer les agneaux selon
leur sexe et leur injecter des minéraux
pour prévenir les maladies liées au
stress
un boulot un boulot d'agneau il doit
être assez homogène à son gabarit et
puis il ya la taille des animaux un
missionnaire une bonne taille ici on
voit qu'ils sont bien gras bien rond
donc c'est de les bêtes passeront 80
jours dans son exploitation
le temps de prendre une vingtaine de
kilos et c'est sur ces kilos
supplémentaires que yoann gagne de
l'argent
565 quoi il sera un peu moins lourd que
la semaine dernière
1902 à les jeter fait le bon tuyau à vos
80 % de sa production à la grande
distribution
ces marges sont infimes on risque de
vendre des nos animaux avec deux ou
trois ou quatre euros de marge donc
aujourd'hui si vous faites pas du volume
vous pouvez pas absorber des charges et
de structure et donc faire du bénéfice
est derrière le midi jeanine la mère de
johan prépare le repas pour tous les
salariés
au menu de l'agneau de la ferme une
viande standardiser les bêtes sont
vendues un poids bien précis pour que
les morceaux entre dans des barquettes
dès les années 70
c'est le père de yoann qui a fait le
choix de l'hyper spécialisation et du
volume
à l'époque les français consomment de
plus en plus de viande pour répondre à
la demande plutôt que d'importer
l'agneau de nouvelle zélande
raymond grimal lui décide de produire
sur place à bas coûts nous on produit en
produits salliot de base et donc
or le produit à un prix correct un prix
que les jeunes en surface peut se payer
si les labels c'est comme le bio tous
ces années là ça va bien des prix bon
bien bien plus cher et il n'y a que
certaines personnes qui peuvent
s'acheter ses produits et de
marchandises là et senio là ils sont
élevés de la même façon que le nôtre
elle seule différence que nous et de
l'acadie est du nombre
l'entreprise grimal fait près de 10
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
annuel de quoi investir dans un
méthaniseur
désormais le fumier qui n'est pas
revendu pour faire de l'engrais peut
être transformée en énergie le biogaz
l'équipement n'est pas encore rentable
mais à terme il espère en tirer de
nouveaux bénéfices
aujourd'hui on n'a pas à rougir je crois
qu'on le vit très bien de notre métier
j'ai choisi ce métier moi parce que
c'était quelque chose qui me dans lequel
je me réalise est réellement l élevage
des agneaux et après bon bien sûr je
gagne je gagne bien ma vie grâce à cette
activité là j'ai pas rougeurs johan
grimal n'est pas agriculteur c'est un
entrepreneur très dépendant de la grande
distribution
à l'opposé de ceux qui ont choisi le
circuit court et la vente directe à la
ferme
mais pour lui il y a de la place pour
tout le monde
bonjour françois bonjour merci de nous
accueillir ici alors on n'est pas sur
votre exploitation qu est ce que vous
êtes sociologue et ingénieur en
agriculture
ces agriculteurs vous les connaissez
bien et ici on est à l'institut national
de recherche agronomique de toulouse
on vient de le voir pour s'en sortir
certains comme la famille grimal ont
fait le choix d'un modèle industriel en
mettant en place ce qu'on appelle des
charmes usine la solution c'est ça
accroître les rendements
n'allons pas trop vite je pense pas
qu'on puisse parler de fermes usines en
france
il ya des exploitations de grande taille
qui sont portées par des financiers
aujourd'hui qui se développe mais c'est
une minorité
en france par contre il y as besoin de
certains agriculteurs puissent se
regrouper et ça passe effectivement de
facto par une augmentation de la taille
de l'exploitation et ils recherchent
parfois de la standardisation mais
surtout une recherche du bien-être aussi
de l'agriculteur qui cherche à avoir des
conditions de travail beaucoup plus
satisfaisante et il faut pas oublier
quand même que la petite ferme familiale
il ya 50 ans était aussi un lieu
d'oppression un lieu d'aliénation pour
s'en sortir l'agriculture française doit
miser sur la qualité sur la quantité
je pense que c'est pas forcément une
bonne question que cette question de
l'opposition entre quantité et qualité
il faut pas oublier que bon nombre
d'agriculteurs bon nombre
d'exploitations agricoles sont
positionnés à la fois sur des circuits
courts et des circuits longs quand vous
allez sur le terrain vous rendez compte
que si un certain nombre de circuits
courts ont pu se développer c'est parce
qu'il ya des abattoirs qui travaille
aussi pour des professionnels qui sont
en circuits longs donc qu'ils proposent
je dirais des produits beaucoup plus
standardisés qui correspondent aussi à
des types de consommation particulier
tous les agriculteurs de tous ne
pourront pas faire des circuits courts
ne le souhaitent pas forcément mais je
pense que on est face à un secteur
agricole qui doit jouer deux produits
cher pas cher accessible surtout à tous
on a vu en début d'émission guillaume un
tout jeune producteur de lait à peine 30
ans est à deux doigts d'abandonner son
métier à sa passion le malaise de la
profession paraît
profond et au delà des problèmes
financiers les agriculteurs sont
aujourd'hui la profession la plus
touchée par le suicide en france
comment on en est arrivé là la question
du malaise paysan est une vieille
question alors je pense qu'il faut pas
non plus réduire la question du malaise
à celle du suicide
aujourd'hui on a une population agricole
qui est de plus en plus effacé sur le
plan démographique il n'y a jamais eu
aussi peu d'agriculteurs et surtout
aussi peu d'enfants d'agriculteurs qui
souhaitent reprendre et c'est pour ça
aussi que quand on traverse une crise
économique comme celle que traverse
aujourd'hui les producteurs de porcs ou
les éleveurs dans leur ensemble
il est beaucoup plus difficile
d'affronter la crise d'autre part à cet
effacement démographique s'ajoute la
question des controverses qui touche la
profession agricole
il ne va pas de soi aujourd'hui que
d'être agriculteur les agriculteurs sont
controversées dans leur pratique
il faut sans arrêt malgré les efforts
qui sont faits s'expliquer et d'autre
part les logiques économiques qui sont à
l'oeuvre dans la profession sont de plus
en plus disparates c'est à dire qu'en
fait à l'effacement à la contreverse
s'ajoutent l'éclatement des types
d'exploitations agricoles
la solution finalement pour l'avenir ce
serait de réussir à faire coexister
plusieurs mondes agricoles je pense que
cette coexistence il faut arriver à la
pensée elle est là déjà elle ne va pas
forcément de soi
on pense souvent qu'il n'ya qu'un modèle
agricole en france peut-on encore parler
véritablement de modèle agricole à la
française face à cette diversité des
logiques économiques qui préside
justement à l'évolution de nos
territoires ruraux
merci françois merci loin du modèle
productiviste pour mieux se rémunérer
certains éleveurs ont décidé de limiter
le nombre d'intermédiaires en
développant des circuits courts
direction la ferme de dix lacs labassère
ge et isabelle ont réinventé leur
profession élevage transformation vente
directe du producteur au consommateur
plusieurs métiers pour plus de liberté
alors on est les seuls dans l'aveyron à
faire du beurre bio et dans une baraque
en bois le bois mène une petite odeur
que sa garde et donc isabelle a mis du
temps avant de savoir faire le beurre à
l'ancienne et c'est la baratte qui va
travailler jusqu'à ce que la crème se
transforme en beurre voilà là il est en
train de se former
la baratte pour toujours qu'elles sont
un peu humide sinon la crème colle sur
les côtés et là je pense qu'il est bon
voilà là il est fait il ya un coût à
voir un canton n'est pas trop habitué
aux débuts au même de plus de tout et
puis après on veut le beurre c'est l'un
des nombreux produits fabriqués à la
ferme de dix lacs dans le nord aveyron
aujourd'hui on y trouve des crèmes du
fromage des glaces mais aussi de la
charcuterie
voilà après on fait saucisses sèches
saucisson saucisse au bleu d'auvergne
poitrine et après des pâtes et si sorte
de pâté petite campagne one that he tout
les produits sur place et vendu
directement aux clients sans
intermédiaire 59 points soit par carte
si vous préférez alors est-ce qu'elle va
capter parce que ça ça marche pas du
jour il est loin le temps où serge
travaillait seul à la ferme depuis que
les rérolle ont choisi la vente directe
le métier s'est transformée à alep pose
alors mais une chose n'a pas changé
ces bêtes sont nourries aux céréales et
au fond qu'il a lui-même faucher
les produits fabriqués à partir de leur
laisse en bio pour nous en produit moins
et on produit de qualité et c'est toute
la chaîne qui va de l'herbe
jusqu au fromage au départ le lait été
vendus en gros à une coopérative puis
les rérolle ont investi dans une petite
machine à berlingo pour empaqueter le
lait et petit à petit ils ont appris de
nouveaux métiers pour le transformer je
me suis formée pour apprendre à faire le
beurre la crème et le fromage blanc le
fromage d'été dans une école pour ça et
donc en est en forme et ça c'est bien
parce que on a appris à faire des choses
qu'on ne savait pas faire c'est
indispensable désormais à dilhac on
n'est plus seulement agriculteurs il
faut gérer la transformation l'emballage
les commandes et les stocks
on va être juste anglais
ça arrive tu as mené vous pourrez alors
du coup là c'est qu'ils biocoop bon
allez hop
impossible de tout écouler dans la
boutique
l'hiver les clients sont trop rares
alors le vendredi isabelle livre les
marchés où les petits commerces du coin
jeux l'état de la chance d'étaler
faisselle le fromage blanc et madame
morte et je vais tout donner pour
acheter tous ces équipements
les rôles ont dû s'endetter à 99% un
pari risqué qui s'est avéré payant
contrairement à la coopérative
ici c'est le producteur qui fixe le prix
est pourtant isabelle n'a aucun mal à
vendre ses produits
bon c'est sûr que financièrement c'est
plus intéressant parce qu'on maîtrise
son prix de vente
mais ce qui motivent le choix c'est
surtout d'avoir le contact avec le
client c'est ça qui est très intéressant
fais ce qui me plaît surtout
la ferme de dix lacs fait partie d'un
réseau de producteurs bio aujourd'hui
isabelle reçoit la visite de françois
mayet un des membres de l'association et
la rillette ont fait l'arrivée
intéresserait quand on fait les deux
sens dans la filière bio une personne
sur deux devant une partie de sa
production en circuit court
si le phénomène prend de l'ampleur c'est
aussi parce que la demande est forte
bah disons qu'aujourd'hui les
consommateurs ils ont besoin de
transparence
ils ont besoin d'avoir confiance dans ce
qu'ils retrouvent dans leur assiette et
ce lien social qu'on retrouve dans la
vente directe
il a une grande importance un lien
social et un choix de vie serge eyrolles
n'a que 40 vaches à lait à lévis alarme
vient c'est la dose quotidienne de ce
sport à les bergères avance bien sûr
qu'on les aime sont toutes nées ici on a
connu leur mère leur grand mère les bb
et b dynamite
serge ne gagne pas plus qu'avant mais il
ne ferait marche arrière pour rien au
monde il ne dépend pas des cours du lait
ni de la grande distribution
ses revenus sont assurés et il crée de
l'emploi pour sa famille et pour son
territoire sur notre ferme il ya six
personnes qui travaillent on reviendra
en arrière il y en aurait plus qu'une
c'est quand même un petit peu dommage
pour pour l'environnement et pour nos
enfants surtout qui vont aujourd'hui
certainement continuer après nous et ça
c'est important aussi
je
voilà itinéraire bis touche à sa fin on
l'a vu au cours de cette émission
certains producteurs résiste à la crise
entre course au gigantisme et
valorisation du terroir un monde paysan
en pleine mutation
guillaume merci de nous avoir reçus sur
votre exploitation ici au coeur de
l'aveyron une terre agricole et qui
entend bien le rester
un département magnifique à bientôt